you like trans women Chris trans women
um yeah why not yeah I've never never
I've never hooked up with one but I'm
one of those guys I can't even really
evaluate if I'm into that kind of stuff
until my father dies like I can't look
at it because I'll kill him instantly if
I was like I like trans you know so but
my dad's like really like even you going
by Robert like my dad would like his
old-school guys he'd be like oh you know
is he gay he would think you're gay
Roberts gay well if you if you're a man
he takes if you're a man and you go by
your full first name it's because you're
gay are you trying to come out of the
Kelly if this is a [ __ ] would cover
on the internet and if you type him and
there's a guy who pees on people used to
Houston yeah I outgrew it no of course
not
don't change your beverage preferences
your dull life so you you you feel like
after your dad dies it's not exploring
sure life well I probably am not gay I
don't know maybe but I I'm probably not
my [ __ ] of his dick he sent me Oh
noted well first of all Joe Joe list
sent me a picture of his dick but on my
day it was his dick but he said it was
Joe's dick so I was like do you got a
big piece well but he sent me a picture
of his dick and they were like I
recognize that sorry oh that's weird you
have Joe lipstick well no but the first
thing I said you how it started was is I
like six months ago
right this girl wanted me to send me you
know send a picture of my dick and I
just I couldn't get hard or I just
jerked off something so I I had on these
gray sweatpants so she's like I really
wanna see you did so I stuck a Time
Warner remote in my sweatpants and took
this picture and it looks like I have a
[ __ ] hog and I sent it out you know
as
dick and then Barbie when I said that
he's like I want to see the real thing
so I [ __ ] yes whoa Robert the real my
dick now I send you my dick pretty often
pretty pretty awful mistake though when
a girl asks for a dick picture to go
sure let me whip one up you have to have
one in the chamber yes for burglar
breaks in you know go allow me to load
up the weapon you have to have it ready
to go yeah right for the dick photo I
have a couple of really good ones I just
send them with yeah take one you put it
on a rig so you have quick access no but
that's a great idea thank you yeah but
you know what now girls because you know
you can tell so much from a photo
they're like I want it right now I can
tell that you took they can press on and
see that it was from another day so yeah
Jimmy they see a [ __ ] Disneyland
symbol on the kneel and hungry I think
he's got a nice piece though I hope so
Stocki Italian if you don't have eight
and a quarter your [ __ ] failing yeah
yeah nice it's a helmet you like it it's
a bit I mean I wish it I wish I could
have a dick like that that USA is that
why you do cuz you hang out with a lot
of the younger comics you do you know
what do you know house in the Hamptons
can I see your dick
no yeah I mean he's the only one sorry
god forbid you hold his hand during this
[Music]
we got it [ __ ] over-explaining
[ __ ] we don't understand Robert he's
the only one who's ever showed me Joe
list Joe Joe list is a little more
creative though because he'll send you a
picture of just him like ministration
next to it the bomb yeah you'll see
you'll look at the picture and then of
us anyway and then you see his dick
hanging out like he'll have it just a
little bit of it and popping out so you
have to Where's Waldo just the box
hahaha list but Joe list will always if
we FaceTime first image is just Joe's
[ __ ] you just said I'm like what are you
doing [ __ ] it and then filing
breakfast with my family and your dicks
out yeah there's something about the
young comics they just whip their [ __ ]
out it's a weird it's all it's kind of
like the car we grew up in that in that
culture well not not like no no no no it
was like sorry it's a new culture
culture there's no expression on your
tongue they're taking a culture
you were [ __ ] killing so now you
[ __ ] bomb hold on oh now all right
we're all clear there's a lot of guys
that are around Chris's age like is that
these are the call he's in a culture you
guys also send dick pics to each others
no and then they go it's that thing it's
a thing where it's like where it's like
do it like we're friends and I'm like
dude let me see your dick and you're
like no I feel like come from Ike why
what are you gay and then you show me
your dick right is that true first it's
reverse gay to show you that I'm
straight and that's how I grew up
we all saw each other's dicks to prove
how straight we were as soon as his dad
dies this blowing every oh god I love
the massage his backside oh yeah we're
taking away from Joe yeah it's not Joe
very funny he's a great singer he's
really good
yeah he draws good too but it's [ __ ]
bombs all that mate I've never seen his
ass what do you think Don Rickles is
Tooting on a dick when he was bored Bob
him and Bob knew our blowing each other
straight which way you're saying it's
the culture with all the young comics
well yeah that's what yeah because it's
the same thing like you said you know
like you know a mark Normand you know
and I are you going the road that's
that's what it is you [ __ ] whip it
out and then we show each other that you
know we're straight we're not into any
weak sauce so you ever the story just as
silver and Lewis Gomez with big J was in
the bathroom and they wanted to [ __ ]
with them so they were like let's lie on
the bed and with our dicks out and so
they're lying there with their dicks out
so when he would come out they'd just be
sitting there with their dicks out and
then they were like well let's get fully
naked and they were a guy so they got
fully naked they're like oh we should be
hard if they do this you're telling me
about this story like I should be like
oh yeah I hear ya
[Laughter]
agreed
would it be funny unless you're hard you
know correct you know what another thing
is to that movie go waiting remember
that movie waiting yeah
2005 so are 2006 so everybody was doing
you know the goat and everyone was like
sucking their dick in the moving their
leg and the movie waiting like there's a
whole bit throughout the movie where you
got to try to get another guy to look at
your balls right creatively right
sneaked around the corner and have your
balls showing yeah hey come here and you
look at my balls
yeah but Everett the big thing was like
you know like you Buffalo Bill you know
put it yeah and do that yeah then lotion
and do that and then what they would
laugh and you know flash back up and you
go I've panting whatever I gotta tell
you Chris there's a couple guys I'm
seeing you have not lost beginning when
I started taking me shaky head and then
I'm reminding you of how you grew up
yeah I really never set my dick to a guy
I'm not in with my crazy
I've never say you never hang out stop
how about a guy with a wig on that's a
different classification just set my
dick to a friend cuz cuz I grew up you
know snapchat with social media
everybody was just digital sending your
dick out it's just so easy and fun and
it's like just funny to send your dick
to your guy friends who's not expecting
it and then you get a call or you
[ __ ] yells at you it's just funny
yeah they promoted snapchat I remember
that what's your name sir Kevin and
Kevin you like that you're with Chris
100% because you're not in the whole
time I mean like it's a thing I like you
got waiting are you the same way to be
like one that gay so yeah of course you
can see my dick yeah I mean yeah it's a
little gay though
yeah why Justin and Lois on the bed nude
that's when they know J is [ __ ]
that's 100 percent yeah but I'm not
prepping you don't know I you prepped
yours for mine yeah that's true but that
is
but that's because I look up to you as a
comic any market just said my [ __ ]
Dan there man just send my sack
scrotum but no you yeah you know I was
like all Bobby I want to impress him so
here's my [ __ ] no it's worthless no
warts yeah no no no I had a wart
I have oh yeah yeah me go that's the
worst day guys give me to each other I
thought I found this out too
I went to a doctor I had because once
you get warts they're there forever is
like herpes right so I had these warts
and they they burned him off the first
time terrible who was the worst
experience ever and then I went back I
had to go back for another thing I went
to a different doctor
they froze him he goes I go last time
they burned him he goes you should never
do that no why he goes when you burn
look when you burn a ward off the actual
smoke from that has the wart [ __ ] in it
he goes whoever was in that room and if
they they they have warts now - Wow oh
[ __ ] doctors have my wart from hope
from Mossad from [ __ ] getting high
off my dick work dick wart wart [ __ ]
yeah and that we award goes airborne
airborne so what happens you see the
smoke coming off it then we'll know we
have a new pope I knew you had a good
one because your eyes
I figured after 11 bombs in a row one
good one was bound to show up how did
you get your warts off Chris I got mine
I had a cream first didn't work and then
I had they froze them off and but for me
it was interesting they brought in
wheezy cream did you just buy like
compound w and just relish it on no no
it's like a medical cream the doctors
like my finger but I had like I had like
five of them like oh so then the doctor
he came in with a bunch of like two
other doctors and they were like trying
like some new cryo treatment they put my
dick and like a like a they like a
interrupted one doctor look at the other
doctor that's Jo Lissa's do they have a
blue cream that goes on your dick yeah
and they use a black light my dick look
like a strippers underwear that's how
they find him but what I did stupid i
funk I got them frozen off and then you
have like open look like it's like a
scab open wound on your dick and they're
like obviously no sex and then like two
days later I think you're a [ __ ] yeah I
know why bandages I bandage it's all
over my dick but then I was just like
you know I went out and there was this
girl and I was like I [ __ ] have to
try so I just ripped it off when we had
unprotected sex and then I got in more
affection in the [ __ ] cuts on my dick
that's when you that's when you know you
have a bad dick when a bandage can stay
on it my dig it would be off yeah your
dick looks like the five pain oh no
12 in a row now he hasn't been sleeping
well Bob I have been up for almost four
days yeah Stan your room stop [ __ ]
going to the gavel Joe have you ever
gone through genital warts or anything
like that oh man just through this are
you married no oh my god so you must be
cleaning up like well yeah for a while
okay it's not the worst let you start to
blow up and do great I [ __ ] how would
you know that's true if I'm gonna have
something about blowing up Bob comments
[Laughter]
no you don't share those feelings with
Jim where you're like oh I'm doing
really well and I have this girlfriend
fob on the road for you but Joe's only
women always like Joey's a cute guy you
know what Peggy a dick yeah yeah no I'm
saying like he's you know Chelsea Lately
was good for you and just you have like
a lot of women with him plus you think
he's really cute what's the big deal
yeah fun energy yeah I could tell
bang-bang a lot which is great which is
great you get out and women know and the
looks it's [ __ ] great the pants I
like it's a it's a good look I'm serious
it's a good look are you taking back
your previous insults about the capris
to say like now they're good look I'm
right [ __ ] here you guys
I'm disagreeing that I can see its
sexuality about you not that it's gay
but I'm just saying I could see that
women are into your father lives a long
time yesterday I can't even respond what
you didn't respond I sent you my dick
Esther I send you the dick yeah and you
said send me the full video I don't have
come on miss patty all this pass here
this crap there's cameras here just so
you know there are cameras this time
yeah miss Pat yelled at me yesterday
last night sit over here sit next she
was mad about the cameras but Miss Pat I
mean hit home run after home run after
home run on yesterday's show can I tell
y'all Bobby Kelly don't know how to have
no black friend
why do you say hi you just keep
snatching me out of it get out of it I'm
like Bobby I got a gloom a wig on I
gotta put makeup on you know I got I got
Tina's I got a pic my titties up and put
them in the Bobby I'm black you just
don't scream come on black girl we gotta
put some things together right look like
a fat cracker like I had a camel toe
yesterday it was not a camel toes my
bottom stomach not position right I love
mr. Pat I'm glad that you're here with
some female energy since you I mean this
morning we've had just as you walked in
here is brilliant because you look very
new growers I'm glad you got my text
you are shows me do you think it's gay
like yes yes yes oh sorry
huh I was just anytime you say that
question I'd immediately yes oh okay
do you think it's gay yes I say to her
glasses and play shorts
is this gay yeah I'm wearing shorts and
no that's what white boys do do you
think it's gay for crocs a guy to send
get a dick pictures to another guy what
what I'm saying if you send a dick pic I
don't have a date no I know if you sent
a dick pic to another like you think
guys sending dick pics back and forth to
each other like if you found your son
sending dick pics to another guy but it
was like haha lol or you know whatever
would would you like this let me show
him how to suck dick of course he's not
yeah it could still be gay though I mean
Chris was saying that he likes to send
dick pics to prove to his friends that
he's not gay
yeah I don't make anything say like if
you like yeah Chris thank you look Chris
Gethard
Chris Keller how are you if I send you
if if I texted you a picture of my dick
would you totally straight okay now you
buy call Chris's you see he's having a
good time maybe he's a little drunk
whatever I'd probably touch myself to
make sure I wasn't gay too
can I show Jim your pee-pee sure let me
see his peepee you have a [ __ ] of his
penis as I'm not gay let me see if
you're gonna show somebody you have to
show everybody he goes which would you
we talked about don't touch other one I
said yesterday hi guys
between yesterday's dick pic oh yeah and
a month before he did it's like a daily
calendar argue Bobby's got seven or
eight different looks from well settle
down with you show into white let's see
your lacks you'd like the horrible this
looks like a journey before you show it
Bobby before he showed do you notice how
Jim is put his hand on his chin and boot
forward
no I'm debating not to miss what like
this and please
well if anybody's a connoisseur I can
see that from here wait wait
from what I'm seeing we're looking at
something quite a surprise Wow looks
like a German so no this actually looked
like I watch open these cameras oh this
look like you're a close-up shot at a
pawn now that you take the rook this
look like this looked like chicken on a
grill at a white barbecue what
white people get season 8 chicken before
a cookie I guess I'm the one who walk
around with this pic right well yeah I
sent it to you okay thoughts I'll be
showing it to all I feel I like it I
like it
oh good I don't know if I it does it
yeah what do you think sir is it bigger
than yours
I don't I don't want to get into a
that's not a little I like it I like it
yeah I like thumbs-up from chris gothner
it's got a little bit of a crabapple
head I would say a little bit of a crab
yeah it's forever Bert what do you think
that's a fat head yeah it is the head I
said the same thing the head is the most
prominent feature presented by you know
I think it's alright okay fine no dick
Jim there's a lot of hail in that
picture if you look at stick by the way
you wouldn't date that girl first
okay well Jim Jim Norton would like to
share his if we're sharing I don't want
to do this now you should share you
should shake Jim knowing you buddy shows
your penis well thanks for spoiling the
surprise miss patch wow this is we doing
it let me pull out my first baby daddy
penis you ain't got no job
let me show y'all what big dicks really
look like
I'm tired of play with those I'm about
to shut this [ __ ] down what was
happening when I showed up Yeah right
scrolling through our phones without
irony all right 92 big bigs Jim are you
gonna are you gonna share I don't know
this is too weird [ __ ] miss Pat once why
I gotta freeze that gets up both arm at
the same time me too
friends mr. Pat would like to see I have
to find them try to show my body bars
hey no Jimmy beetle you've never sent a
nude picture of yourself or of a body
part to anyone well I got a two stomachs
so if I put your camera down its gonna
get real cloudy mom like are you stuck
in the rain I'm like no there's not a
job for [ __ ] vijana has an atmosphere
I can fill my cigars near vagina and
keep them fresh
they might come back who the taste but
it'll be fresh you better throw up
really taste like sriracha say that
right yes are we ready Jim to present I
guess I'm gonna go ahead and say this
feels slightly non-consensual Jim you
seem like this is so depressing he's
trying to be bashful no I just said it
feels you here in front of an audience
to show your penis to your friends he's
trying to be bashful but you have some
standards yeah yeah so Bob would you
like to do the duties of carrying the
phone like that thank you thank you Bob
our beautiful motto Bob Kelly let's give
him a round of applause looking really
good today looking really good - my own
apartment would it first of all Bob
what's your grab Jim's my class it looks
like a reindeer if you show miss Pat
last I think miss Paso still made the
black people go away that's right
it's kind of a show oh and what an
upward curve does car BOTS
haha it's a true salary up you might
definitely keeps just thank you very
much much a very Christmasy right my
dick has a positive attitude what do you
think
is she really you and this makeup no I
want to say don't wave it all over Patti
did real quick what Patti was when Bobby
held her handed her the phone she
accidentally pressed the folder and
there was a series of dictators that's
why she responded like Jesus they're all
chewed on color all the same day I gotta
say dude he got a curve no she didn't
have no you don't have no balls when
they beat you if you look me different
angle if you look at Chris's picture his
hand is in there and then it gets to
perfectly and you go those parquet
floors are real hardwood you know funny
question Bob those were not the best
floors I feel building I live that on
all seven floors now we're better miss
Pat this is clearly a victory for Jim
Norton
you're like I gotta tell you this Jim
when I was little I used to like
wrasslin so that's like the kind of
object for the wrestling ticket which
city was this Atlanta what year see you
you don't want to say that was you
Atlanta Chris Gethard are you a are you
a dick pic sender
uh no I'm I'm a married man right and
but you don't you don't you won't send
her photos from the road or something to
keep it really it's happened very rarely
it's happened but you know we see each
other often enough this is such a weird
thing to say but she sees my dick live
and in person often enough sure that she
doesn't need photographic evidence
alright what about you Joe you have a
year in a committed relationship I send
you you just you're on this
international tour you're on the road
for two months are you sending dick pics
to keep it fresh no you're not no I just
don't get the dick pic well sending it
to someone in a relationship I wouldn't
do that you're just doing with your
friends you have to be a guy went to
high school with you only going to white
community
I'm tell you sit a black man of dignity
will beat you down no they have that no
they have that lecture on black Twitter
what is that the eggplant fried eggplant
Friday we're the guys but that's that's
for women still kind of weird you
remember waiting on Nicki Minaj
boyfriend dropped his dick feet oh my
god poor that dick up
oh I'm to you it was a merry-go-round oh
it was the I'm telling you I sent it to
everybody's like bless you [ __ ] bless
you it was a nice cyst
I mean it was like whoa you could get
two [ __ ] karate yeah yeah well so
Vince dick oh yeah no yes no which guy
seen Wilson Vince D monster car
everybody thank you sure to China yeah
don't worry about my vagina I'm just
telling sometimes just like the Lukas
you know how you walk up a mountain and
you eat ice cream yeah so sometimes you
just like I could use a soft sir we
walked up the [ __ ] mountain we get up
there stay he goes they have no water no
what kind of country is this I said yes
ma'am I know yes that fella job okay
then he comes out with a [ __ ] ice
cream in his hand yeah that's a [ __ ]
true fatty tries to suck water out of an
ice cream hill